on est atomisé on n'a plus de vie quoi
c'est une un acte gratuit est immonde
[Musique]
lorenzo a été violemment agressé il a
été poussé par ken ken parole donc un
jeune par derrière il s'est retrouvé
dans un fossé sur le ventre et un autre
une autre personne à notre individu a
complètement sauté dessus se sont ils se
sont acharnés sur 100 bio
[Musique]
il est très faible il a eu des graves
des gravol un des graves séquelles il a
eu des grosses infection pulmonaire ou
6,8 à à tous à toutes ces blessures très
très lourde ont engendré tout un tas
d'autres problèmes derrière ses muscles
de la 2d cordes vocales ont été en cette
année est complètement sans sans
fonction pendant plus de trois mois donc
c'est tout une rééducation ça aussi
[Musique]
alors moi j'attends tout simplement que
justice soit faite à hauteur de l'état
de lorenzo pour qu'on puisse en 2020
agir de la sorte et être tranquillement
en liberté parce que pour moi c'est une
tentative de meurtre donc ces gens là
sont des assassins des gens qui sont
dangereux pour moi déjà la justice se
sera jamais à la hauteur de son état
mais au moins qu'ils justice moi parce
qu'on peut pas agir comme ça c'est
impossible
[Musique]